Our climate is changing.
The choices we make affect the amount of greenhouse gases we put into the atmosphere.
Making a few changes around the office can cut carbon emissions.
Shut off your computer, monitor and other electronics when you're not using them.
Turn off the lights in rooms you're not using and at the end of the day.
Buy Energy Star qualified office products, like copiers, printers and computers.
Green your commute by walking, biking, taking public transportation and carpooling.
Recycle paper and plastic.
Print on both sides of the paper.
And buy office products that use recycled content.
Reduce your carbon impact to the environment.
Act now on climate change.